Dormammu I've come to bargain
[Music]
this is ukk Cecilia's powers from your
dimension I brought a little power for
mine
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have a never-before-seen
deleted slash unused scene in Avengers
in game of Dormammu returning to Earth
setting it up to where he will most
likely return for Doctor Strange to
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness now this has been expected and
theorized about for a while but today we
finally get a confirmation as the script
for Avengers endgame has been released
and with the script being released we
see an alternate scene between the
ancient one and professor Hulk in the
original scene and Avengers endgame she
explains to the Hulk what happens when
you remove one of the time stones how it
creates an alternate timeline well in
this alternate scene it shows her
removing more than one Infinity stone
and it also shows Dormammu returning
setting him up to return for Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness so
let's breakdown the scene and talk about
dormammu's return and Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness quick reminder
to subscribe to my channel with
notifications turned on like and comment
on the video so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 so let's go to the script and
read how this scene was exactly supposed
to play out in Avengers in game
originally so this picks up right where
she removes the time stone from the time
line she says now your time line might
benefit my new one would definitely not
she gestures our camera zooms into the
blackened tunnel tunnel point of view
hundreds of people run as we fly over a
crowded Street up to the burning Hong
Kong sanctum the ancient one continues
in this new branch reality without our
chief weapon against the forces of
darkness our world would be overrun move
up to see Dormammu in the sky he opens
his mouth back on the roof the ancient
one plucks more stones from the golden
River creating five more black and
tributaries for each stone you remove
you'll create a new vulnerable timeline
millions will suffer now tell me doctor
can your science prevent all of that and
then from there the script is what we
saw in avengers endgame but this scene
is very very interesting because what
the ancient one shows here in the scene
is a
initially a glimpse into the future of
what would happen to earth without the
time stone but that's the thing the main
MCU timeline right now that everybody
exists in does not have a time stone
Thanos destroyed all of the Infinity
stones reducing them to atoms including
the time stone and as we learned from
the first Doctor Strange and as we
learned from the ancient one in Avengers
in game with this new script the time
stone was the only thing protecting
earth from Dormammu dr. strange was only
able to defeat Dormammu by trapping him
in a time loop with the time stone well
now the time stone is gone which means
Dormammu can return and there's nothing
to protect Earth from him now this is
called Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness so he will most likely go
into a different timeline another
reality and get a time stone from there
to protect Earth but it seems like
Dormammu is definitely on his way
especially when he finds out that Doctor
Strange no longer has his main defense
against him and although nightmare has
been rumored to be the villain for
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness nothing is confirmed yet and
this alternate scene in Avengers endgame
seemingly sets up the premise that if
the time stone is gone Dormammu will
return well the time stone is gone which
means Dormammu should be on his way
especially if you consider the fact that
it's been five years since the time
stone has been destroyed and not to
mention Doctor Strange was technically
dead for five years as well so if
Dormammu has found out that Doctor
Strange is dead and the time stone is no
longer on earth that means he is
definitely on his way and of course he
will probably make it back to earth
right around the time that Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
comes out so this new alternate scene
for Avengers in game with Dormammu has
confirmed the theory that we've all had
for a very long time now if the time
stone is gone though our Mamu will
return so let me know what you think
about this new alternate scene that has
been revealed and let me know if you
think that we'll see Dormammu and dr.
strange and the multiverse of madness be
sure to comment below like the video and
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 don't
forget to click the link down below for
your chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet
and don't forget to use code cosmic @ G
fuel comm for 30% off your G fuel as
always thank you all so much for
watching will fluff